وجدت صورة انفجار في البنتاغون
اليوم طريقها إلى
شبكات الأخبار الدولية وتسبب في
تراجع سوق الأسهم ولم يكن هناك انفجار في
البنتاغون ، لكن الصورة التي سنعرضها
لك إنها مزيفة
ولهذا السبب وضعنا الذكاء الاصطناعي المزيف
الصورة هناك يبدو أن الذكاء الاصطناعي
هو الجاني دوني
أوسوليفان من CNN معنا الآن وتوني من أين أتت
هذه الصورة المزيفة وكيف
انتشرت هذه المعلومات المضللة بسرعة كبيرة
نعم جيك هناك جزءان حقيقيان من هذا
الحق ، أولهما هو إيلون ماسك
قد يتذكر الكثير من مشاهديك على Twitter
القصة بأكملها حول علامات الاختيار الزرقاء
على Twitter ، فإن علامات الاختيار التي تم التحقق منها
قد أخذت في الأساس كل
هؤلاء بعيدًا ، وهي تبيعها الآن للأشخاص
الذين يرغبون في الحصول على علامة اختيار زرقاء ،
لذا بينما من قبل  إذا كان لديك علامة زرقاء
على Twitter ، فهذا يعني أن Twitter قد
تحقق من أنك الشخص أو
المنظمة التي تدعي
أنها ليست كذلك ، فما
حدث هذا الصباح هو أن شخصًا ما
نشر باستخدام حساب
زعم أنه مرتبط.  إلى
منظمة بلومبيرج نيوز أه نشر أن الذكاء الاصطناعي
أنتج صورة وأن الذكاء الاصطناعي
كان قد حدث نوعًا من
الانفجار
في البنتاغون ثم تمت مشاركته
عبر العديد من الحسابات الأخرى التي تم التحقق منها
والتي رأيناها على منصات أخرى أيضًا ،
بدت منسقة تمامًا ولكننا لم نفعل ذلك.  لا
أعرف الآن من دفع هذا
الأمر ، فهناك جانب الذكاء الاصطناعي من هذا ، لذا فإن
العديد من الخبراء الذين تحدثنا إليهم
وغيرهم ممن لاحظوا هذا عبر الإنترنت يقولون
إن هذه صورة تم إنشاؤها بواسطة
الذكاء الاصطناعي ويمكنك أن ترى
هناك على وجه الخصوص الأشخاص الذين
تعرف واشنطن أن
المبنى أه في الصورة ليس
البنتاغون لكنك تعلم أنه يظهر فقط
حتى مع مزيف خام مثل هذا أه
وبعض الحسابات التي تم التحقق منها على تويتر
أم أنك تعرف أنه لا يزال من الممكن أن تسبب
الكثير من المتاعب  لسوق الأوراق المالية للانخفاض
وخداع بعض المؤسسات الإخبارية